what's your goal with the foundation  trying to get the stigma away from  talking about mental illness and suicide  to be very specific talking about  suicide in different ways we hope we can  be a voice through Tim because Tim had  so many millions of hands so his destiny  yeah yeah like Stan legacy and on the  internet we open his site for the fans  to communicate we didn't want to use his  site after his death but they  communicated so we we got so many  fantastic replies and support so we  understand so we think that we can help  a little here yeah it's a great demand  for help yeah how did you decide this is  what you wanted to do to honor your son  because of his problems it was natural  to trying to do something that can help  other young people in that situation